[Music]
we're headed to a
warehouse this one has a lot of european
shipments south american shipments
a lot of source countries for us for
narcotics
so let's see what we can find over here
yo but take a look at this ecuador what
is that
i don't know let's find out
it's like blankets echo is a big transit
point now for dope coming out
from south america heroin cocaine we
used to get stuff in the embroidery of
this
inside the lining a lot of times what
they try to do is
nickel and dime so they put little
baggies of coke inside little
handicrafts you always got to check you
got to cut it open
this one is what it is all right i've
seen enough yeah
[Music]
coming from mexico told food and
breads and he got peanuts
tamales looks like a lot of shipments
coming from mexico
mexico big source country cocaine heroin
a fentanyl every bath
you know meth everything so what they
like to do is they like to conceal it
inside the food a lot of times
they think it's gonna fool the x-rays or
they think it's gonna fool us you know
we're not gonna take a look at
but we take a look at everything
you know we have to
look like giant cherries those are
chilean apples those are bigger so it's
a different fruit
it's not is sticky
it's funny that those are a different
color
we got powder i said
there's another one now we're separating
the actual contraband itself from the
fruit
i wish they'd chosen something that was
less syrupy
they think we're not going to get our
hands dirty what do you got there
five seven this one has yep seven
what we do now we're gonna use our
gemini machine to just confirm
[Music]
there you go it's cocaine hydrochloride
yeah wait arms
0.391 kilograms
i mean they were not greedy not greedy
at all
we have to dig through all this food to
get a small
load you know we've been seeing more and
more smaller amounts
i think they're testing out different
concealments and see what they can get
through they don't want to lose a big
shipment
now we're going to notify hsi they're
ultimately going to take possession of
the narcotics themselves
and they may do a controlled delivery to
find who this was going to
and then perhaps develop a case from
this at the end of the day it's about
disbanding these drug trafficking
organizations
this shipment here this is just one of
those three or four hundred
that come in multiple times a day
see what else they got
[Music]
you